y
[Música]
luego a la donde dice
el
pp
dice que formaría la vivimos más famosas
en el mapa
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión de los
observadores de france 24 y comenzamos
en túnez porque en septiembre nuestra
reacción fue alertada sobre unos vídeos
grabados en ese país sobre el trato
inhumano a unos migrantes procedentes de
áfrica sub-sahariana ellos fueron
detenidos cuando intentaban cruzar a
italia por guardacostas luego fueron
llevados a un lugar totalmente
desconocido un autobús y fueron dejados
a mitad del desierto uno de estos
migrantes accedió a hablar con nosotros
pero vamos a llamarle eric por proteger
su identidad
nos enviaron allá nos subieron a un bus
nos llevaron a un lugar donde nunca
habíamos estado que no conocíamos nos
preguntaron por nuestra nacionalidad y
luego nos mostraron la carretera y nos
dijeron sigan la carretera vayan sea
libia
preguntamos por qué ni siquiera querían
que habláramos dijeron cuando vayas allá
lo entenderás te vas a morir vete a
morir que allá había mujeres entre
nosotros ancianas que tenían miedo que
lloraban nosotros también seguimos la
carretera algunos se fueron a libia
otros se quedaron en el desierto
ante toda esta situación 8 ongs tunecina
firmaron un comunicado en conjunto
denunciando lo que ocurría y conversamos
con una de ellas
con la audición de este tipo de
expulsiones cada vez más frecuente y
cada vez lo vemos más a través de videos
aficionados publicados en las redes
sociales
no conocemos realmente el motivo de
estas expulsiones
pero desgraciadamente pensamos que el
estado tunecino considera que estas
personas piden de libia y por tanto
procede a una devolución siendo que
estas personas fueron interceptadas en
el mar
túnez carece de infraestructuras para la
acogida de migrantes y suponemos que
este es un factor importante que empuja
a las autoridades a recurrir
precisamente a estas deportaciones
asisten o abajo hacia su auto de lujo
como éste
por otra parte de libia sigue siendo un
país inseguro sin legislación sobre el
derecho de asilo y cuya violencia y
tortura contra los migrantes muchos de
los cuales se encuentran en un estado
muy vulnerable han sido denunciadas
repetidamente por la comunidad
internacional
estas organizaciones denuncian que es el
pasado 12 de octubre no tiene ningún
conocimiento de estos migrantes
devueltos a libia además nuestra
reacción se puso en contacto con el
ministerio del interior tunecino y no
tuvimos ninguna respuesta
desde hace unas dos semanas la carretera
está bloqueada la carretera está cerrada
un vehículo puede pasar
es lamentable
hablamos con otro observador gaspar
gordi de costa de marfil él nos quiere
mostrar la situación que se vive una
carretera al oeste de ese país hablo con
los residentes con camioneros y también
con habitantes de la zona y nos envió
sus testimonios
y
todo el mundo está en el barro en este
momento ayer vinieron dos máquinas a
despejar la carretera pero no pudieron
porque el agua sale del suelo
sólo los más valientes como los
motociclistas intentan pasar
de lo contrario todos crucen con sus
maletas en la cabeza
[Música]
estamos prácticamente a la entrada del
departamento detalle por tu poder
agrícola es un pulmón económico esencial
en la región de cabal
y todas las actividades están bloqueadas
las mujeres productoras de alimentos
lloran porque no pueden vender sus
productos
[Aplausos]
llevo cemento me voy a hacer llevo una
semana aquí vas a volver a él y lo voy a
volver al hilo porque no podemos
trabajar aquí también hay que buscar
dinero llevamos aquí una semana ni
siquiera podemos comer bien aquí
esta carretera fue arreglada
provisionalmente el gobierno marfileño
aseguró que antes de 2025 va a arreglar
la completamente
y terminamos esta emisión de los
observadores en república centroafricana
con un observador de ese país llamado
cristian en total nosotros fuimos a 2019
a esa nación para apoyar un proyecto de
reconciliación de su país es también un
rapero franco centro africano llamado
befa centro sacó un vídeo llamado wang y
edu o bungee es agradable veamos parte
de este vídeo
en miami ciudad ficción cansan cuando se
les acabe tuviéramos yo sigo tan grande
que no quiere hacerte ver por el palacio
legalmente viator chiquita
[Música]
y tú
sí
no se lo hizo solo
y por favor no dude en enviarnos sus
fotos y videos aficionados todos
nuestros contactos aparecen en pantalla
y no importa en qué parte del mundo se
encuentre queremos agradecerle al
restaurante o gps en la ciudad de bogotá
por prestarnos sus instalaciones para
grabar esta emisión de observadores en
france 24 hasta una próxima oportunidad